erica is with us in Arizona hi Erica
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Danica thank you so much for taking my
call it's a pleasure to speak to you
both Jim I have a question about child
support so I am grateful to say that I
am actually on baby steps we've got all
my debt paid off but my child's father
was about maybe fifteen or sixteen
thousand in child support in arrears and
so because I had been able to you know
kind of get through this you know myself
so far to pay off all the debt that I
had just wanted your thoughts on if I
should just you know stop the the
frustration and hassle of trying to take
him back to court to get him to pay
he has another child on the way as well
on his own but I just wanted your
thoughts on it I should let that go or
if it's still something that you think
that I should pursue I'm grateful that I
think able to get to this point so far
praise God okay let's pretend that you
got a phone call this afternoon from an
attorney and a rich relative that you
didn't know had died and left you a
million dollars okay in other words your
financially let's just pretend for a
second you're completely financially set
how does that change his obligation to
pay for his child it doesn't okay so the
point is not that you are okay the point
is is that this is his kids money and a
guy ought to pay for his kid unless you
have you been abusive or have you been
to him or have you abused the court
system or is he not really oh what they
you know if they ripped him off in some
way or you know I mean there are some
child abuse child abuse there are some
child support cases that are over the
top and they're wrong in terms of what
they're charging the father there's no
question about that those exist but you
didn't mention any of that so I'm
assuming that's not there is is this a
proper amount of child support and he
just has chosen not to pay it what's the
deal it's
low it's only 260 and months they have
we did the agreement maybe like six
years ago when minimum wage was a lot
lower in our state
there's only 260 a month and uses to pay
20 dollars towards arrears as well
making it so to Edie but no it's not
extravagant at all and you say his
dollar amount he's behind is 15 to 16
grand he's never paid it on Wow yeah
Eric you you definitely need to have a
conversation and get back to court and
walk through this you know the reality
is as David saying you got to got to
take care of the kids now I wouldn't I
wouldn't spend you know 90 percent of
your emotional energy doing this but I
would continue to put some steady
pressure on him because it's it's
incumbent upon him morally forget the
legality of it to take care of his child
dads are supposed to feeding their
babies yeah does feed their babies he
see the baby it took the child at all
uh-huh does he come to the in visitation
every other weekend you see them
consistently yeah I think you've been a
little too easy to get a long ways sweet
girl okay I just wanted to make sure cuz
I feel so grateful that I paid off
thirty four thousand I would be grateful
if I inherited a million dollars too but
that has nothing to do with him being a
deadbeat okay my gosh I just wanted to
see your daily point of view so thank
you so much I appreciate it that's just
my opinion and I think you've been way
too nice is what I'm afraid of
well and she's able to move forward
despite that's good but this is what I'm
thankful for
yeah I'm grateful for opportunity I'm
grateful over in America I'm grateful I
can work on very [ __ ] save money but
this guy's never paid I know
so no intention to no just showing up
picking up the kid yeah